Nhanh dịp cùng tham sự hồi gí cấp cao Asia lần tiêu bụng hi vậy và các khuận gí cấp cao lên quan tại thú đu của la Lam Pơ của Malaysia.
Chương ngày hais sau tháng người thủ thuy trị phụ và mi chính đã có cuộc tiếp xúc ngắn với tổng thống hoặc gí đô nơi chăm,
bây lề hội gí cấp cao Asiaan Hoặc gí.
Tại cuộc tiếp xúc, hay nhà lễ gạo thống nhất quan tâm, thúc đẩy quan hiện đu tác chế lực toàn dịp,
vì hoặc bình hợp tác và phát triển bình bứng, giới Việt Nam và hoặc gí, ngày càng đi vào chữ dấu thức chết và hiểu qua.
Chăm ra có việc sống kí kết hiệp định thương mại đuối ứng, giữa Việt Nam và hoặc gí theo hướng công bằng bị đăng,
thúc đẩy đồ tư của hoặc gí vào Việt Nam.
Theo để sốt của tự trình phụ và mi chính, tổng thống đồ nơi chăm phản hồi tích cực,
và gí nhận để gí công nhận Việt Nam là nên kinh tế tị trường.
Đưa Việt Nam ra khỏi dành xách sốt khẩu chính lực, đi một đi ba,
và chỉ đạo các quan chức cao cấp hoặc gí, nhiều bụ trường cây chính.
Đại diện thương mại đang có mặt tại hồi gí, sớm phản hồi về các bình đi này cho Việt Nam.
Bột tự trình phụ cho biết Việt Nam đểng xa khá phai trọng của tổng thống hoặc gí đồ nơi chăm,
trong việc tốt đầy sẽ quế thoại vì các nghiệm nống xung đồ trình dưới vửa qua.
Cuộc các bên lề hội gí, ASEAN hoặc gí, giữa hai nhà lĩnh đạo,
dù ngắn, nhưng đã thị hiện sự hiểu biết tôn trọng lẫn nhau và thống nhất,
tiếp tục thuộc tựng mạnh mẽ thức chất hiệu qua quan hiệp đuất chế lực tọn diện giữa hai nước.